Traduttore: Inesse Saidani
Revisore: Erica Colleoni
Bello questo piatto, vero?
Adesso ve lo spiego.
La cosa più importante,
quando si fa un piatto,
è riuscire a fare in modo
che i nostri ospiti,
dopo averlo assaggiato,
se lo ricordino.
Per sempre.
Per questo, oltre a essere buono,
un piatto deve avere
anche una storia da raccontare,
deve avere un'idea.
In questo caso,
la Glaciazione del Würm.
Un evento, che 10.000 anni fa,
ha permesso al salmerino alpino
di diffondersi
sulle Alpi, nei laghi
delle Alpi.
E solo in pochi laghi del Trentino,
si è conservato
fino ai giorni nostri.
E proprio per questo, la scienza
lo ha anche definito
un 'relitto glaciale'.
Deve poi essere
espressione del territorio,
ma vivendo da diecimila anni
nei laghi del Trentino,
è fortemente identificativo.
Deve
avere una novità.
Avere una tecnica nuova.
Avete visto che io ho versato un liquido,
non è altro che acqua e sale:
è una soluzione satura,
di acetato di sodio,
che rimane liquido,
finché non viene perturbato,
da quella bustina,
con all'interno del ginepro
e dell'olio essenziale al pino mugo.
Tornando solido,
rilascia calore e questo calore
crea, ricrea una sensazione,
dell'ambiente di montagna.
Avvolge gli ospiti,
suggerendo l'ambiente della montagna.
Un piatto, poi, deve anche stupire.
E,
l'amaranto è un ingrediente lontano,
che uno non si aspetterebbe
in un piatto così.
Apparentemente sconnesso ma
riconducibile per l'esperienza del cuoco,
per la mia esperienza.
Lavorare in questo modo,
rende la professione del cuoco
straordinariamente coinvolgente.
Perché rappresenta ciò che si è,
ciò che si sente
di essere.
Io ho iniziato a fare questo lavoro
quando ero un ragazzo.
Ero affascinato dalle mani
di mia nonna, che vedevo impastare
gli gnocchi.
Così,
ho frequentato la scuola alberghiera,
mi sono diplomato,
ho lavorato in grandi alberghi,
in Italia e all'estero.
E sono stato al fianco
di un grande maestro:
Gualtiero Marchesi.
Tutto questo,
potrebbe farvi pensare che io avessi
sempre avuto una visione
nitida, un'idea chiara
della mia professione.
Eppure,
non è così.
Ho capito di amare veramente la cucina
solo pochi mesi fa.
E l'ho capito,
grazie ad una crisi.
Una profonda crisi personale,
che alla fine dell'anno scorso,
mi stava togliendo la passione.
Mi stava togliendo l'entusiasmo,
mi rendeva scontroso
e lentamente consumava anche la fede
in me stesso.
Non credevo più nelle mie possibilità.
Sta di fatto,
che mi sono trovato di fronte
ad un bivio.
O mollare tutto,
oppure ripartire.
Ho scelto di ripartire.
E l'ho fatto tornando
ad un mondo
che sentivo vicino.
Il mondo delle mie origini,
quello della montagna.
Con i suoi ritmi,
i suoi
paesaggi, con il gusto
delle cose semplici.
Comunque,
sono ripartito
da un viaggio.
Un'avventura,
semplice,
attraverso le Alpi,
che ho pensato e sviluppato,
seguendo una logica del rispetto,
del risparmio di risorse.
Cercando di restituire l'ambiente,
così come l'ho trovato.
Senza lasciare tracce.
Muovendomi esclusivamente
in cammino,
oppure volando in parapendio.
Sono partito,
sono partito da Trento,
con l'idea di arrivare
a Pollenzo, in Piemonte,
alla facoltà di Scienze Gastronomiche.
Volevo che questo viaggio
fosse significativo per me,
ma anche per il mio modo di essere
e per il mio lavoro.
Così ho fatto una prima tappa,
al Giardino Botanico Alpino,
qui al Monte Bondone, alle Viote.
Sono passato dall'amico
Norbert Niederkofler,
autore di una cucina
di montagna etica e rispettosa.
Ho visitato il museo di Messner,
a Plan de Corones.
E in Val d'Ultimo,
insieme ad alcuni amici
che mi avevano raggiunto,
ho sperimentato quella che amo definire
una cucina di prossimità,
estemporanea.
Pensate che per 20 giorni,
ho camminato, risalendo le montagne,
ho volato,
attraverso le Dolomiti,
il Vallese, il Monte Bianco.
Ho visto scenari
straordinari.
Ho anche incontrato difficoltà,
ed ho sofferto.
Tanto che, in alcuni casi,
stavo quasi pensando di abbandonare.
Invece ho continuato,
sentivo la voglia di continuare,
sentivo la necessità,
di stare da solo, di ritrovare tempo
per pensare, per guardare,
per dormire.
E in questi momenti,
di solitudine e contemplazione,
ho ritrovato una connessione.
Qualcosa ha iniziato a riattivarsi,
a rigenerarsi.
Ho ritrovato l'entusiasmo,
ho ritrovato l'energia,
mi sono sentito più forte.
E anche più giovane.
Per questo,
vorrei lasciarvi
un messaggio,
che sento, nel valore del volo.
Perché il volo,
è conoscenza.
È relazione intima, con l'ambiente,
ma anche con se stessi,
con i propri limiti.
Il volo è scuola di vita e carattere.
Ci insegna a riconoscere
la passione,
la tenacia, il coraggio.
Il volo è equilibrio,
è lo stesso,
che cerco nei miei piatti.
È l'armonia, la capacità,
di far convivere
due elementi distanti.
Il volo è bellezza.
Ed è coraggio.
Il coraggio di ripartire,
di rompere gli schemi,
di uscire
dalle convenzioni.
L'educazione,
ci rende adeguati alla società,
ma spesso
limita e atrofizza le nostre qualità.
Chi vola, invece,
ha voglia di andare oltre.
E tutte le volte che decolla,
tutte le volte che muove il primo passo,
sa che da quel momento in poi,
accetta un rischio,
ma sa anche che avrà dei momenti
bellissimi.
Un regalo, intenso, fatto di bellezze,
di profumi, di colori.
Questo
viaggio, questo volo,
mi ha aperto gli occhi,
mi ha fatto capire
che tutti questi valori,
li potevo ritrovare nella cucina.
In quello che faccio tutti i giorni,
nella creazione di un piatto,
nelle difficoltà che condivido
con i miei ragazzi,
nella scelta
dei prodotti migliori,
nell'uso della tecnica.
Mi sono reso conto,
che il volo,
rappresenta ciò che stavo cercando
nella mia cucina.
E così,
sono tornato da questo viaggio,
con uno sguardo nuovo.
Con una fiducia e una forza nuova.
Ora,
dopo avervi raccontato
questa mia storia,
la ricerca del viaggio,
le emozioni del volo,
Vorrei che anche voi provaste a volare.
Pensate
al vostro lavoro
o a quello che fate nella vostra vita.
Poi, pensate
a una vostra grande passione.
Cercate
e combinate i valori
che questi due mondi, così lontani
e apparentemente opposti,
condividono.
Trovare questi valori,
capire
cosa muove veramente la passione
dentro di voi.
Questo è volare.
Ora,
vi saluto con un verso di Montale
a cui sono particolarmente affezionato.
E che qui, oggi,
evoca un po' il senso
di tutta la mia storia.
La necessità di trovare un equilibrio,
di trovare un'armonia.
Chi trascina i piedi nel fango,
ma ha gli occhi nelle stelle,
quello è il vero eroe.
Quello è il sol vivente.
Grazie.
(Applausi)